en russie internet a jusqu'à maintenant
été synonyme de liberté
mais les choses pourraient changer
l'arrestation et l'emprisonnement et
l'opposant alexeï navalni au mois de
janvier a changé la donne fait noir de
vladimir poutine
le voilà privé de son principal outil de
mobilisation les réseaux sociaux mais
ses partisans ont rapidement pris le
relais dans la rue et en ligne
provoquant la colère du kremlin
depuis moscou ne cesse d'accroître son
contrôle sur le web
alimentant les risques de désinformation
damart altérer ce corps bienvenue aux
décrypteurs alors évidemment plusieurs
obus dans l'arrestation d' alexeï
navalni un point tournant à partir de ce
moment là dit notamment comment s'est
déployée la contestation du régime sur
les réseaux sociaux
elle était omniprésente elle était
époustouflante surtout chercher une
tranche d'âge qui écoutent pas la
télévision d'état qui n'écoutent pas la
propagande donc les techtoc surtout qui
est une plateforme où les re sont
sur-représentés ya peu près 30 millions
d'heureux s'abonner à techtoc c'est le
pays le plus populaire site etc toc toc
toc est devenu instagram facebook sont
venues des plateformes pour inviter les
gens manifester car alexis navalni est
revenu au pays
la première chose qu'il a fait avant
d'être amenée par la police et est
emprisonné c'est qu'il ait dit sortez
dans la rue
faites-le pour votre avenir et ce
message là a été retransmis à une
vitesse éclair sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya certaines images certains symboles
qui sont devenus vraiment des prétextes
pour convaincre le gouvernement qu'il
fallait sévir contre les médias contre
les géants étrangers du web des images
d'élèves par exemple qui disait aux
jeunes comment manifester quoi porter
quoi dire aussi avec un accent peut-être
étrangers américains américains pour se
faire épingler par par la police pour
des cons et étrangers arrêtés nous pas
et aussi ces images de jeunes qu'on a vu
dans leur salle de classe où il ya
toujours une photo de la dmr poutine ici
en russie
décrocher le portrait du tableau et le
remplacer par celui de naval liste à ce
moment là où on a vu le désir du kremlin
de faire des réseaux sociaux étrangers
surtout son nouveau champ de bataille et
comment le régime le kremlin vladimir
poutine
si son prix justement pour resserrer cet
étau et reprendre le contrôle du message
si on veut mais ils n'ont pas repris il
essaye et certains diront désespérément
vous savez on a demandé à tik tok à
facebook instagram et à tous et de
retirer des milliers de messages que le
kremlin jugé offensant ou qui selon
kremlin faisait l'apologie de thèmes
comme le suicide la drogue ou encore la
pornographie juvénile ayant tik tok qui
a et on en a la preuve pour avoir parlé
à des jeunes qui sont très présents sur
ces réseaux sociaux là qui ont vu leurs
publications disparaître soudainement de
leur fil d'actualité mais le kremlin a
une loi des outils qui lui permettent
dorénavant d'exiger des géants étrangers
du web de retirer du contenu et s'ils ne
le font pas c'est sous peine d'amendé ou
encore avec la menace d'être bloquée
complètement en russie est l'exemple de
twitter est assez éloquent vous savez il
ya deux semaines le losc hommes d'athor
qui est un peu le crtc de la rue s'il
sait c'est celle agences
gouvernementales qui patrouillent
internet a donné un ultimatum à twitter
dit si vous ne passez pas les messages
qu'on juge offensant on va vous bloquez
et depuis je vais vous montrer à quoi ça
ressemble tous été en russie est
toujours disponible mais c'est
extrêmement frustrant on en ralenti
l'accès donc tout ce qui est photo tout
ce qui est vidéo est beaucoup plus lent
à ceux téléchargés ou ne se télécharge
pas du tout moi ça me rend gaga parce
que je suis une utilisatrice de twitter
comme journalistes une source
d'information certains diront c'est pas
une catastrophe si tout à disparaître du
portrait médiatique ici en russie parce
que c'est pas la plateforme la plus
populaire on dit qu'il ya 3 10% des
russes qui sont sur twitter mais qu'on
s'en serve comme terrain d'essai pour
envoyer le message qu'on est capable de
censurer et de bloquer des médias
sociaux étrangers c'est ça qui envoie un
message à s'inquiétant pour pour les
gens qui ne peuvent plus passer
d'internet en russe
en 2019 le gouvernement russe adopter
une loi qui s'appelle la loi sur
l'intérieur l'internet souverain ça a
pour but de débrancher éventuellement la
russie du world wide web de l'internet
mondial
mais en attendant que ça se fasse très
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup passé peut-être
trop même de temps sur tik tok ces
derniers jours et on a pu constater que
le kremlin a trouvé preneur chez des
lions youtuber j'ai des jeunes testeurs
coeur qui publie maintenant des messages
où ils disent exactement la même chose
mot-à-mot on soupçonne qu'ils sont payés
à eux aussi pour faire l'apologie du
kremlin jacques rigueur on a déjà des
n'aura pas toujours très gai on y voit
le point le gouvernement russe se sert
tout autant de ses plateformes pour
faire passer son message
avec des conséquences je présume tamara
sur la désinformation qui circule dans
ce pays
ce que ça va en s'accentuant cette
désinformation avec ses récentes
manoeuvres de moscou vous savez la
désinformation c'est le risque des
réseaux sociaux même dans les pays où
ils sont les plus libres la
désinformation qu'on peut constater au
canada aux états unis en france ou en
russie vient du même problème que ce
sont des espaces complètement libre mais
c'est sûr que ce sont devenus des outils
qui est là je sais des jeunes à qui on
ne parlait depuis quelques semaines
c'est le seul outil le seul espace
complètement libre en russie la seule
façon pour des gens qui pensent la même
passion et qui veulent exprimer leur
opposition au gouvernement de le faire
en toute liberté
donc ce qu'on craint bien sûr c'est que
cet espace la liberté soit de plus en
plus restreint est ce que le
gouvernement est capable de priver toute
une génération qui a grandi avec un
téléphone dans la main d'un état d'un
internet libre même s'il en a les moyens
on doute que ce soit dans l'intérêt du
gouvernement russe de le faire pour des
raisons sociales mais aussi pour des
raisons économiques